>> Ben: THIS WEEK THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AT THE BEHEST OF JOE
BIDEN DECIDED THAT THE PARENTS
WHO STAND UP FOR THEIR KIDS AT
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED AS TOE MESS STICK
TERRORISTS.
THEIR MESSAGE IS LOUD AND CLEAR
TO MOMS AND DADS ACROSS AMERICA.
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH THE RADICAL
LEFT, YOU ARE GOING TO BE
TARGETED AND SILENCED.
BUT MANY PARENTS ARE FIGHTING
BACK.
JOINING ME NOW IS ASRA NAOMI
WITH PARENTS DEFENDING
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
JOIN ME TONIGHT.
I CAN SEE THAT SIGN THAT'S
BEHIND YOU.
WHAT ARE YOU TAKING THAT TO?
>> WELL, HERE I SIT, I'M RIGHT
OUTSIDE LUTHER JACKSON MIDDLE
SCHOOL.
THE SCHOOL BOARD IS GOING TO
HAVE A MEETING TONIGHT.
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE 100 PARENTS
OUTSIDE WITH SIGNS LIKE THIS.
THEY ARE STANDING DEFIANT OF
THIS THREAT BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI TO SHUT
THEM DOWN.
PARENTS ARE GOING TO STAND UP
DEFENDING CHILDREN AND DEFENDING
EDUCATION.
>> Ben: DO YOU THINK THAT YOU
ARE GOING TO BE GETTING SOME
ATTENTION FROM THE FBI, PERHAPS,
AFTER TAKING SUCH A STANCE IN.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
PARENTS ARE SAYING THINGS LIKE
BRING IT ON.
ARREST ME.
THERE IS NOBODY WHO CAN STAND
BETWEEN A MOMMA BEAR AND PAPPA
BEAR AND THEIR CUB.
IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE WHAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS DOING.
WHAT THEY'RE REALLY DOING IS
PROTECTING POLITICAL AND
BUSINESS INTEREST THAT LEAD
RIGHT TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND THE EDUCATION INDUSTRY THAT
IS EXPLOITING OUR CHILDREN AND
SO WE HAVE TO RETURN BACK TO THE
ABCs AS ONE MOM JUST TOLD ME
AND STOP WITH ALL OF THIS
INDOCTRINATION.
>> Ben: AS REMARKS I KNOW THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU WOKE UP TO
PERHAPS EARLIER THAN MANY IN
THIS COUNTRY IN TERMS OF THE
DEVELOPMENT THAT PLAYED OUT OVER
THE PAST YEAR PLUS, TELL ME A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR REACTION
THOUGH TO THIS -- WHAT I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY
NEVER COULD HAVE SEEN HAPPEN IN
COUNTRY PARENTS BEING TAGGED AS
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS POTENTIALLY
FOR WANTING TO SEEK OUT THE BEST
FOR THEIR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION?
>> YEAH.
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE TO ME.
MY FATHER CAME TO AMERICA IN THE
1960s AS AN IMMIGRANT FROM
INDIA.
WE LIVED IN POVERTY OUR FIRST
YEARS.
I WAS ENGLISH AS SECOND LANGUAGE
STUDENT.
I LEARNED ENGLISH WITH NANCY
DREW.
I COME INTO THIS COUNTRY AND I
BELIEVED THAT EDUCATION IS OUR
STEPPING STONE, RIGHT?
MY SON WENT TO ONE OF THE BEST
HIGH SCHOOLS HERE IN FAIRFAX
COUNTY, VIRGINIA.
BUT THEY TOLD OUR MOSTLY
IMMIGRANT, MOSTLY MINORITY
PARENTS THAT WE HAD TO START
CHECKING OUR PRIVILEGES JUST
BECAUSE OUR KIDS WERE AT THIS
SCHOOL.
AND THAT'S WHEN I WOKE UP AND
REALIZED THEY WERE PUTTING A
TARGET ON THE BACKS OF PARENTS.
AND NOW WE HAVE THAT CONFIRMED
WITH THIS RIDICULOUS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT DECLARATION OF WAR ON
US.
PEOPLE HAVE TO BE VERY CLEAR
THAT -- STAND CLEAR FOR YOUR
VALUES AND BE UNAPOLOGETIC AS A
PARENT.
BRETHREN.
>> Ben: I REMEMBER BACK, YOU
KNOW, 20 YEARS AGO THERE WERE A
LOT OF CONCERNS BEING RAISED IN
THE WAKE OF THE PATRIOT ACT
ABOUT IT BEING MISUSED AGAINST
DOMESTIC PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY
AGAINST MUSLIMS IN AMERICA.
>> RIGHT.
>> THIS SEEMS LIKE THE KIND OF
THING THAT SHOULD AROUSE THE
OFFENSE OF EVERY AMERICAN,
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER YOU ARE ON
THE RIGHT OR THE LEFT TODAY.
>> EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN SHOULD
BE OUTRAGED RIGHT NOW AT THIS
OVERREACH BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
I AM MUSLIM.
I HAVE CHASED TERRORISTS AROUND
THE WORLD.
I HAVE GONE TO GUANTANAMO BAY TO
STARE MOHAMMED SHEIKH MOHAMMED
IN THE EYES.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THESE
PARENTS, THEY HAVE NAMES LIKE
HARRY AND STACEY AND SABERNA,
THEY ARE GOOD PEOPLE JUST LIKE
PARENTS ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS WAGED
A WAR ON THE WRONG PEOPLE.
WE ARE THE PROTECTORS OF
CHILDREN.
AND THEY MUST STAND WITH US.
NOT AGAINST US.
THIS IS SO, SO DISHEARTENING.
BUT, WE WILL NOT BE DISHEARTENED
BECAUSE WE HAVE CLARITY IN OUR
EYES AND THOSE ARE THE FACES OF
OUR CHILDREN.
>> Ben: ASRA, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
YOUNG ME AND GOOD LUCK AT YOUR
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING.
>> THANK YOU.
I HOPE EVERYONE GET